aquí tenemos nuestro interruptor
deslizante de un polo y doble tiro no es
un interruptor de palanca de un polo y
doble tiro como el que vimos
anteriormente este es un poco diferente
observa tiene esta palanca deslizante
hecha de plástico
y conecta la corriente eléctrica entre
este contacto y este contacto o entre
este contacto y este contacto y bueno se
dice que tiene un polo y doble tiro
porque tiene un polo en el centro y dos
tiros a los lados entonces vamos a
desarmarlo para ver de qué está hecho y
cómo está hecho por fuera está hecho de
una manera bastante ingeniosa observa
que la cubierta está hecha de acero
bañado en níquel y en lugar de usar
tornillos o pegamento lo que hicieron
fue tomar una hoja plana de acero y
doblarla para formar la cubierta de
manera que todo se mantenga en su lugar
y crear así una buena cubierta
esto se puede soldar una componente de
la tarjeta de circuito para encender y
apagar lo que estés construyendo y bueno
claro puede ser usado nuestro robot para
encender y apagar las luces así como los
motores
ahora desarmamos el interruptor para
conocer cómo es por dentro y ver de qué
está hecho entonces lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es
estas pequeñas pestañas vamos a
doblarlas hacia afuera
y puedes usar las otras pinzas para
sostener el interruptor mientras
desdobla las pestañas ya que son muy
pequeñas y es difícil es difícil
desdoblar los
entonces doblamos las pestañas hacia
afuera de ambos lados del interruptor
y toma un poco de tiempo porque las
pestañas son muy pequeñas pero aunque
son muy pequeñas son lo suficientemente
fuertes como para sostener el
interruptor en su lugar
ahora solo falta desdoblar una última
pestaña
ahí lo tienes muy bien ya que
desdoblarse las pestañas verás que hay
una pequeña tableta y esta tableta tiene
unas cuantas piezas de aluminio
atravesando las son tres piezas de
aluminio puedes ver que la que esté en
medio corresponde al polo tiene una
pequeña joroba y eso es importante
porque lo que hace es hacer que la
palanca deslizante del interruptor se
posicione correctamente y así no se
atore entre las dos posiciones ahora
vamos a estudiar la palanca de que está
hecha la palanca cómo funciona la
palanca del interruptor está hecha de
plástico abs puedes ver un pequeño metal
dentro de la palanca que permite a la
palanca deslizarse ese metal se desliza
entre los contactos así
entonces cuando está en esta posición
veamos vamos a estudiar las posiciones
de la palanca
entonces
se cayó el pequeño contacto el contacto
que permite a la palanca deslizarse
muy bien entonces cuando está en esta
posición
estos dos contactos están conectados y
cuando están en esta posición
de esta manera la palanca estará en
posición que determinará por cuál de los
dos circuitos fluirá la corriente
ahora la manera en la que esto se
mantiene en posición está hecho con
bastante ingenio a mi parecer aquí
dentro hay un resorte este contacto
conduce electricidad entre las dos
conexiones y aquí hay un pequeño resorte
que presiona hacia afuera ese contacto
para que el contacto tenga una buena
conexión entre el polo y los dos tiros
ahora eso es importante porque porque
sin ese resorte el contacto no estaría
firme no habría una buena conexión es
decir el resorte permite que el contacto
no se levante
porque si se levantan no habrá corriente
eléctrica circulando de manera constante
ahora una cosa más estamos usando este
interruptor como un interruptor de un
polo y un tiro
es decir no estamos usando ambos tiros
entonces lo que podemos hacer es doblar
uno de los tiros hacia afuera pues no lo
necesitamos solo necesitamos uno de los
tiros y bueno ahí tienes el interruptor
de palanca deslizante de un polo y doble
tiro el cual estamos usando para estado
por dos motivos es barato y hace bien el
trabajo